okay my name is uh brett that's uh
b-r-e-t
last is ficklin that's f isn't frank
i-c-k-l-i-n
i'm a lieutenant with the las vegas
metropolitan police department traffic
bureau
uh today at approximately 2 15 there was
a nissan pathfinder directly behind me
that was in the far right lane going
westbound bonanza
that had been stopped at the signal
at bonanzan eastern the
pathfinder got a fresh green and started
through the intersection
when there was a white mustang
that was northbound on eastern in the
far right lane
that failed to stop for the red signal
for that side of traffic and that
mustang struck
the pathfinder once those two vehicles
collided the pathfinder continued
forward
and collided with a 26 year old mother
who was
at the northwest corner of the
intersection walking with her
five-year-old son and a daughter that's
about to turn two years old uh
the mother and her two children were
transported to
umc trauma the children fortunately
have non-life-threatening injuries
unfortunately the
young mother did not survive the
collision
the driver of the pathfinder was also
injured in the collision
was transported to sunrise trauma and
she also does not have
life-threatening injuries the
driver of the mustang has remained on
scene
and we do not believe impairment
is a factor at this point we are
fortunate that
we have several witnesses that have
remained on scene
plus we have video surveillance from the
businesses in the adjoining area
that have helped us to uh come to a
conclusion as to
what happened here today and will help
us to uh
to clear up this investigation
well the the three main causes that we
have people killed on our roadways
are speeding impairment and failing to
yield the right-of-way
and of course anytime somebody blasts
through a
red signal or blast through a stop sign
there's a good chance that there's going
to be a collision and there's a good
chance that it's going to be
a violent collision um
[Music]
we understand that uh everybody has we
all have our
things that we have to do we we all have
schedules that we try to keep
up with um but the important thing to
remember is if
is if you if you don't if you don't
you can't make it to your desk final
destination
uh if you're involved in a collision if
you get killed in the collision
um a lot of people
like to pride themselves on being
multitaskers
and i tell people all the time that when
you're driving a car that's not a time
to be multitasking
when you're in the car your sole purpose
is to be focusing
on what you're doing at that time and
being aware of
not only what you're doing but being
aware of everything around you
and so uh especially this time of year
uh our our violent collisions our
fatalities tend to go up this time of
year
uh you know it's understandable that
with the holiday season and
uh with the current circumstances that
we're all uh facing with the pandemic at
all
people have a lot of things on their
mind but we would just ask that people
focus on
especially when they're on the roadway
that they focus on what they're doing at
that time
and and not try to concentrate on other
things
because their life
and the life of everybody else around
them on the roadway or
on the sidewalk may depend on it
we have the holidays
well the you know when you when you put
things in perspective and you look at
all the
you look at all the steps that uh we're
doing
locally statewide nationally for the
pandemic the whole purpose of that is to
is to save lives is to keep people from
getting killed
um it's the same thing on the roadway
you know what the the steps that we take
the messages that we send out
the enforcement that my officers and the
other jurisdictions do throughout the
valley
the whole purpose of that is to make our
streets safer
is for is to help people be aware that
um
you know what uh the roadway is a
dangerous place
um the laws are there uh based on
science
the speed limits that are set on the
roadways are based on science
and uh when you start messing with the
science
that's when the problems arise
we're truly looking to save lives to
keep people alive and to keep people
from getting killed on the roadway
and so our message is to people is to
be aware of what's going on um
take care of business on the roadway
when you need to be taking care of
business on the roadway and
and uh and be look out for other people
whether you're a pedestrian or a driver
or a motorcycle rider
uh we we want you to we want you to be
uh be able to respond and to arrive at
the locations
that you're supposed to go to and i
share this with speeders all the time
you know what it's better to arrive late
than to never arrive at all
yeah today this will be 97 this will be
our 97th
fatal for this year and the the kicker
of all of this
is every one of those events
was preventable every single event is
preventable
this is something that does not have to
happen but it continues to occur
and so we just need to be cognizant of
that and make sure we're doing our part
to make sure we're looking out for
others
usually in an investigation like this we
anticipate that it'll be closed for
about four hours
so i had to say that we'll be here at
least another three
what what type of charges could the
driver compensate
that's that'll be yet to be determined
uh we have our fatal investigators out
here
um uh and that's yet to be determined
based on the
full outcome of their investigation
any other questions
uh that's again uh that'll be in the
hands of the fatal
fatal investigators um once they work
through the investigation
uh they'll come to that conclusion